I'm Charlotte Rally,
uh,
as Tara said,
I,
um,
lead our women's initiative at Mckinsey.
And this is a topic that's near and dear to my heart and I assume pretty timely
and a topic right now for all of you.
Um,
I'm going to share some of our,
the insights from our women in the workplace research that we do together with
lean in.
We're in our second year of doing a survey of approximately about 130 companies
were participated,
about 34,000 participants.
And those companies represent about almost five or four and a half thousand for
four and a half million employees.
Uh,
so a lot of great insights that we've been able to get out of the data.
Um,
and as I mentioned,
this is a topic that's really near and dear to my heart.
So as in addition to spending a lot of time on women's issues that Mckinsey,
I'm a mother of,
I have a daughter and you know,
I'm,
I'm always thinking about a,
you know,
how is this world going to be different when she is in the workplace and how can
we make that happen together?
So before I get into the research,
I wanted to lay a little bit of the groundwork for why this is a topic that
people should care about.
Um,
other than a lot of the obvious reasons.
The economic case is real.
So we did research and our power of parity research,
uh,
where we looked at different regions across the globe and estimated what the
impact would be if women achieved parity.
And that's impact is about 28 trillion.
If we close the gap,
uh,
you know,
recognizing that slightly unreasonable,
uh,
we also said,
well,
what if each company within its region where,
sorry,
each country within its region,
we're able to reach parody at the or the pace of change of the fastest changing
countries in the region.
And that's how it has an impact of about 12 trillion.
So this is a huge number obviously,
and something that we all need to care about
in the u s this impact is about two point 1 trillion.
So this is bigger than the GDP of Texas.
Um,
and there's three main gaps,
uh,
to close in order to get parity.
One is participation.
So in the U S it's about 40% of the GOP is participation,
30% from moving people from part time to full time and then 30% productivity.
And that's,
that's essentially people in lower wage or lower productive jobs or sectors.
Um,
and with pay gaps.
So if those things closed,
we would see,
um,
two point 1 trillion.
So at the company level,
what's the case for change?
We typically look at it in four lenses.
So one is the more obvious,
most eyes or values,
right?
The second one is around talent.
Third is performance.
There's actual link to performance and gender diversity.
And finally the customer,
how are we actually relate more to our customer base that's making decisions?
Primarily,
there are a lot of women making the decisions in the household.
So first if you think about values,
um,
women make up a huge of the,
the,
the workplace,
right?
Um,
but if you look at their pay gap,
women are making about 80 or 20% less than men.
And furthermore,
there's actually a differential in what happens when the performer,
there's positive versus negative performance.
So in positive,
in times of positive performance,
women tend to get less of a bump.
Um,
Sharon less of the upside and actually get penalized more when there's negative
performance.
So the meritocracy,
while it's important,
and it's something that we all talk about,
it's not there yet.
Talent.
So winning the war for talent,
needless to say means getting more women.
Today,
college graduates,
women that are college graduates represent 58%,
um,
of the,
of the college of graduate population.
And so if you want it,
if you want to get talent,
you need to get talent.
Women both right out of college,
but also at every stage in the pipeline
performance.
There've been many studies and I know you've done a lot of study studies at,
at Google on the power of diverse teams and diversity of thought.
The research that we've done shows that gender diverse companies outperform by
15% and ethnically diverse companies outperform by 35%.
So there's a real case for,
for performance in diversity,
uh,
and finally the customer.
So women are making a lot of the decisions at the household.
This is obviously in the BTC world.
Um,
but if you think about that actually having a diverse organization that's
serving those households is quite important.
So now let's turn to the women in the workplace.
Uh,
research for starters.
Um,
the,
uh,
we've been benchmarking this for about 10 years.
We've been benchmarking and studying women in the workplace,
the pipeline,
the data forever,
for about 10 years.
Over the past few years we've also started expanding to two.
Also benchmark and look at the experiences and attitudes of men and women as
well.
So we'll get into that.
Um,
but when you look at the trends,
the data trends of the pipeline,
it's going to take,
given how the glacial pace at which we're moving,
it's going to take about a hundred years to reach gender parity in the sea suite
a hundred years.
So I'm personally hoping that we can speed that up a little bit because I'd like
my daughter to be able to have a better chance and not have to wait till my
great granddaughter to see Parity.
So what does the corporate pipeline look like?
And this is us data by the way.
But when we look at the European data,
it's relatively similar.
The corporate pipeline is not looking great.
So our results from this year reaffirm what we keep seeing over the past.
We've seen over the past 10 years,
we chose,
women are represented at every level in the pipeline,
in the organization,
and the numbers aren't changing much year after year.
We're going to come back to this one.
But despite a misperception,
this is not due to attrition,
right?
This is actually due to promotion and some and other factors.
And so we'll come back to that.
If you look at women of color,
it's even worse,
right?
It's even more stark.
So at the SeeSuite instead of 17%,
you see 3% for example.
And if you look at some of the wallstreet journal research on the ambition of
um,
women of color,
black,
Hispanic and Asian women are 48% of them said they aspire to be a top executive
compared with 37% of white women.
So there's not a lack of ambition on the part of,
of women of color.
So now going back to it to attrition,
it is not the driving factor.
And this is a very common misperception.
And clearly this is a mythbusting piece of data.
But if you look at this is attrition by tenure and men actually attrite faster
than women,
which means it's not that women are leaving,
right?
And often,
look,
the one caveat to this is this doesn't necessarily say where the men are going.
So they might actually be going into another,
uh,
a position similar to another organization.
But still,
um,
if you look at this,
it's not saying that the reason why we're not we're,
we're losing women at Seymour senior levels is because they're leaving.
So let's talk about the challenge.
The challenge starts early at the very first milestone for every 100 women
promoted about 130 men are promoted at the first promotion.
So this is from the entry level position to manage our,
for example.
And then we also see discrepancy and hiring throughout the pipeline.
So what that means is it just keeps getting worse.
So,
not only are we promoting men at a faster rate at the earlier stages,
but then we're also bringing in more men throughout the the funnel.
Uh,
and furthermore,
we're promoting women at a slower rate.
So all of these things are contributing to the state of the pipeline.
So now let's turn for a moment to the second part of what I had originally
mentioned,
which is not just the pipeline data but the experience data.
So what are the attitudes of men and women in the workplace and how does that
explain some of the data?
So I'm going to start by getting a little bit of involvement from you in the
room.
So first question,
raise your hand if yes.
Has Your gender been a disadvantage as you've climbed the corporate ladder?
Yes,
it has.
Raise your hand if it's yes.
Okay.
First of all,
it's great that a lot of you have not had that issue,
but I do see if I look around the room,
probably more women raising their hands,
uh,
which is consistent with the data.
So if you look at the data,
women perceive more disadvantages based on their gender and the gap keeps
getting wider as you go more senior.
And when we look at the actual qualitative data behind the survey,
women consistently report feeling that their comp contributions are often valued
less than men,
um,
that they're being turned to less than men for important decisions,
uh,
that they're participating less meaningfully and meetings.
And often there were receiving fewer challenging assignments than men.
Other research that we've done often shows that men get stretch assignments and
are promoted based on potential,
whereas often women are promoted on performance and the history of their
performance.
And one other factoid on millennials,
which is you'd hope that this is changing for millennials,
but actually millennials have answered these questions in very similar ways,
um,
to the rest of the workforce.
So another question,
raise your hand if yes.
Do you have meaningful access to senior leadership?
Yes.
Okay.
All right.
Better.
So men and women also report having different access to senior leaders and
networks.
So this is also another case where the gap grows and particularly at more senior
levels where access to senior leadership is especially important for sponsorship
and for promotion,
it gets worse.
And what are the reasons behind this also has to do with networks.
So women tend to have networks.
This is our research shows that are 50,
50 women,
men and in men tend to have networks that are primarily male.
So if you then think about within my network,
just if you do the math,
it has to be true,
right?
That women just had smaller networks.
If that's the case,
because we know that there are so many more men in senior ranks or they have
smaller networks of senior leaders.
And so what does that mean?
Obviously we need to get more women in senior positions,
but we also need to,
uh,
make sure that men are mentoring women.
That's a big,
big gap.
We'll come back to that one.
But often people tend to mentor others that are very similar to themselves.
Um,
they don't feel as comfortable.
Men might not feel comfortable taking a woman out to drinks if that's the way
that mentorship relationship begins and things like that.
So how do you actually start becoming very,
and this is a call to action for the men in the room,
how can you get really purposeful about thinking about who you want to mentor
and sponsor within your organization?
Which women you're going to really take under your wing?
Cause that makes a huge difference.
So how about this?
Do you re do you feel that you've received as much feedback as your peers?
Raise your hand if yes.
Okay.
A little bit of a mix,
a little bit of the next.
Um,
so our research shows that women receive less feedback than men,
um,
mass and more specifically the,
the tough developmental messages.
Okay.
So,
so what does that mean?
Especially as you get more senior hearing the tough messages that help you
develop is extremely important to developing and progressing.
And not only women,
men,
but women actually have a heart.
I have a harder time given that giving the hard telling the hard messages to
other women.
So both men and women worry that they're going to create an emotional response
or that they are going to be perceived as mean or hurtful.
I mean,
this goes back to a lot with unconscious bias,
but by giving a woman feedback,
and if you think about that,
I mean that's doing a tremendous disservice,
tremendous disservice because we know that people grow through developmental
feedback.
And so how can we all ask ourselves,
are we doing that right?
Are you giving the hard but important messages to women in the same way that
you're getting to men?
And if you're not,
how might you shift your mindset to say,
you know,
this is my intention is to help this person grow.
And so being mean or hurtful is not the issue.
It's about using the intention of the positive intent.
Yeah.
So have you ever been called aggressive,
intimidating,
demanding or bossy?
Oh,
okay.
This is a great culture.
I'm with you.
I'm raising my hand too,
by the way.
Um,
so the good news is,
this is we,
we looked at this from the following angle.
We said,
how many people are more likely to negotiate,
whether it's for higher pay or I'm a promotion or something else.
Are you willing to negotiate?
And the good news is that women aren't negotiating at the same rate as men.
So we're,
we're doing it.
But the bad news is that women get unduly penalized,
right,
for being bossy and aggressive.
So what that means is that,
um,
when,
what that means is that the percentage of women and men that were called Bossy,
aggressive or intimidating is much higher for those,
that Nigga,
for the women that negotiated versus the men.
And,
and by the way,
19% of the women who didn't even say they negotiated feel like they're being
called those things a lot of the time.
So how do we change the game?
Let's talk about changing the game.
Three things we've seen in companies that are the best.
And so first of all,
I'm going to start by saying this is a,
we are,
as,
as we saw in the data,
we are in far from where we need to be.
Um,
and no one company has cracked the code.
So there's nobody that's figuring it out and doing it tremendously well.
Lots of companies are trying different things and having success in different
ways,
but nobody is,
has cracked the code.
But we looked at some of the companies that had over 30% women in the CSUITE,
right?
So those that were doing the best on this dimension.
And we said,
what are three,
what are some of the things that are common?
So three things and we'll dive into them in a minute.
So one is,
um,
persistence.
Many of these companies,
including Mckinsey,
has been at this for,
for 10 years or more,
right?
We've been talking about it,
we've been looking at the data,
we've been trying different things and you know,
it takes time.
It takes time and commitment.
The second one is the CEO commitment.
So this is not a social,
you know,
nice to have thing on the side.
This is a true priority from the CEO and this is commitment that cascades all
the way down the organization and the way that any business initiative would.
That's number two.
And then number three is holistic change programs.
So the,
again,
it's not about a bunch of policies or programs on the side,
but it's the holistic change programs that engage people throughout the
organization that include all the metrics and the data and monitoring the way
you'd run any major holistic change,
transformation.
All of those elements are true.
So let's dive into that last one for a moment.
Yeah.
The first part of that is really making a compelling case change for case for
diversity.
It's not just about saying it.
So if you look at this,
right,
almost 80% of companies claim that gender diversity as a priority,
but the,
but the employees don't really buy it.
Okay.
So this is the percentage of people in different labs.
The percentage of people that say,
my manager,
our sales leaders or my senior leaders or my CEO consider this a priority.
They don't,
they don't buy.
The companies are actually making it a priority.
And why is that?
Well,
we looked at some of these organizations and,
and even companies that look great on paper,
they've got amazing policies.
They've got work from home,
they've got flexible work style,
they've got parental leave.
They have lots of community events and effort.
Um,
but if they're not walking the walk,
if it doesn't,
if it's not clear to the organization that it's actually okay to take advantage
of those programs and that it's championed that you're a part of those things,
people don't do them,
they might exist.
People don't do them.
They think,
you know,
going on a longer maternity leave is a kiss of death.
That's my walk down the path of the,
the,
um,
the downward cycle.
So companies also therefore need to be talking about it,
right?
There's lots of companies that are talking about it.
I think you're probably,
you're,
you are all talking about it a lot right now and we can continue to talk about
it,
but how do the CEOs need to be very clear that this is a priority,
that there's a business case behind it,
that we're making it happen.
And so here's just a couple of examples of organizations like P and g and JP
Morgan that are really putting muscle behind,
making this a priority for the organization and talking about it a lot.
So secondly,
this is about policy.
And procedure,
the way in which you do hiring,
reviews,
promotions,
um,
making sure that there's real equity there,
there's real gender discrepancies in how people perceive fairness at work.
So people really feel that,
that it is not quite as fair as the companies say it is right.
That I'm in,
particularly women feel that,
you know,
promotions and um,
and getting opportunities,
they are at a disadvantage.
We've talked about that before within the data.
Um,
but how do you have to change that?
So there are a few things,
right?
If you look at just how do you do it in the different stages of talent
management.
So hiring reviews and promotions,
a big thing,
particularly with hiring but also within reviews and promotions is unconscious
bias.
Um,
so how do you really figure out ways to remove unconscious bias?
So there's,
um,
that have,
that are doing blind resume screening that are bringing in,
you know,
new games and ways of applying to the,
to the,
um,
to the organization that don't,
that don't require,
you know,
seeing somebody face to face,
but it's rather looking at their work or looking at or listening to their music
or what have you before there's a face to face interaction.
So there's absolutely no bias.
And those organizations that have done that type of blind screening actually
find much more parity in their hiring practices.
Um,
you know,
vmware for example,
this is in the,
in,
in the,
um,
uh,
reviews,
they actually train managers right before they were right over view to,
um,
to,
to remove unconscious bias.
So they remind people about gender biases.
They remind people about potentially loaded phrases like women,
you know,
needing to have more presence,
things like that.
Um,
and,
uh,
and they write it,
they have a memo and every manager is required to read and write before they
write their performance reviews.
So putting it top of mind in people right at the moment of,
of writing review.
Um,
similarly on promotions,
I'm often,
there is a,
you know,
some organizations are requiring that slates for promotions always have a
certain percentage of women on them.
That's not to say that the women are getting promoted.
It's not a quota,
it's not a quota for promotion.
It's not meant to steer the actual promotion itself.
It's just meant to say,
often what happens is the slate doesn't have enough women on it and so it ends
up going to a man.
So if you actually just make sure the slate has it,
that ends up having impact.
And again,
keeping in mind that the promotion itself is based on,
on meritocracy,
but that it's just the slate that has been sort of forced to,
to really make sure that people are removing their bias and putting,
putting different,
different profiles on it.
So the third is accountability and results.
So focusing on accountability and results.
And we've talked about this,
uh,
you know,
a bit and the idea that um,
if you don't measure it,
it doesn't happen.
Right?
Like,
if you can't see it,
if you don't measure it,
if you don't call it out,
if people are not accountable to these,
um,
metrics,
then it's not going to do anything.
Right.
And so if you look at this,
I mean 40% of companies are saying they hold their leaders accountable for
performance against gender diversity.
Going back to 80% of the companies say it's a priority,
but only 40% are holding leaders accountable.
Um,
and a very small percentage of employees agree that the progress is actually
being measured and gender diversity is being measured.
So some of the things that we're seeing here are how can you literally just,
um,
how are different organizations publicizing their pipeline,
their funnel,
um,
how,
how different managers are doing.
Um,
oftentimes managers don't even realize what they're doing.
So by actually giving them the data,
um,
this is how many people you interviewed last last year and this is the
percentage of them that were women.
And this is your promotion rate of women.
And this is the way in which you've been.
And you know,
if you go through and look at all your performance reviews,
these are the types of comments you have on women versus men really starting to
bring to light.
What's happening is a way to create a lot of uh,
a lot of visibility and opportunity.
Yeah.
You know,
for example,
Ikea has made achieving a 50,
50 gender split.
One of the key metrics that managers are evaluated on,
okay.
Salesforce publishes diversity numbers as we all know,
right?
In 2015,
Mark Benioff said that he had the goal to employ an equal number of women and
men and thinks that this is absolutely doable and is on the,
on the path to doing that.
So how do you start to set those goals and measure them empowering employees to
lead the change?
So one of the things always we've also found is paired with the whole numbers
game and really making sure that you're getting diverse numbers and you're
tracking of etc is inclusion.
So how do you,
how do you get more inclusion?
And that's something that has been,
I know nick,
probably a very big part of how you all operate,
right?
With the focus on diverse teams and diversity of thought.
That's,
that's,
that's exactly what we're talking about it how do you actually create a,
um,
environment that feels inclusive for,
individuals of all different types of backgrounds.
And that's a way to help him create inclusivity for women.
Um,
and that's about culture and culture change happens all the way down the
organization with every last person and engaging change agents and engaging
people in different pockets of the organization to really drive this cultural
change.
So lastly,
of course,
educating people,
right?
Right.
Now,
most,
most employees don't know how to promote gender diversity,
right?
There's a lot of people that say we want to do it,
but there's not a lot of people that know how to do it.
And whether that's telling your middle managers that,
hey,
if you just literally chew,
if every man in the middle management chose to mentor a sponsor,
one or two more women,
how much impact that could have?
Okay.
Um,
if senior leaders chose to sponsor another woman,
if Jude senior leaders chose to speak out and make this a priority and really
cascade this down the organization,
the way in which that can move the needle.
And even at the entry level,
it's how can you really promote inclusive practices from day one so it doesn't
feel like a frat or you know,
a certain type of environment that is not welcoming to women or other types of,
um,
uh,
or,
or other diverse backgrounds.
Okay.
And then role modeling,
and this is part of it as well.
So actually calling it out,
I mean this is how women and men answered whether or not people managers are
calling out gender biased language or behavior.
It is not,
okay.
If you hear someone say something that's offensive,
you just call it out.
I mean,
imagine if everybody called that out.
It just wasn't tolerated.
That makes a huge difference,
right?
Embracing different leadership styles.
I think that this is better than calling out,
you know,
styles that are or,
or activities or language that is negative,
but being able to embrace,
there's lots of different styles.
And there's lots of different ways to be successful here.
And we're going to role model those different ways and,
and,
and celebrate different profiles.
So building this generation of diversity champions,
training them,
celebrating them,
modeling that,
modeling it,
right?
Let's,
how,
you know,
how can you celebrate people that are diversity champions?
We,
you know,
even at Mckinsey,
we're starting to do that,
right?
How do we celebrate people that are doing,
making a real difference?
And that's a huge honor to those people and things like that really start to get
people excited and motivated,
training them as we talked about before.
But what do they need to know?
How do they need to behave differently?
How can they make a difference?
And making sure that your modeling and role modeling what you want to see.
So what can you do today?
These are a few things.
I'd love to actually even open it up and hear from you what you all think you
can do.
Um,
but some of the things just to start the conversation around talking about why
gender diversity matters to you both up and down.
I'm calling out the biases,
as we mentioned,
not tolerating any behavior that is,
but is demonstrates bias,
um,
creating scorecards and measuring and monitoring,
changing your language,
just reminding yourself to use that,
remind yourself to think about it.
Sometimes it's just as simple as that.
Committing to sponsor women,
um,
and sharing in success stories of women's celebrating women that had done
amazing things.
So what are some of the,
what are,
what are some other things?
And by the way,
I'm also open to take questions,
but I figured I'd start with a question to you,
um,
which is what are some of the things that you're doing about it or that you're,
you think Google should be doing about it?
Okay.
Um,
well my manager who's sitting two minute,
two rows behind me and with my team,
uh,
Yep.
Uh,
made the suggestion that we use a regular,
regularly scheduled kind of tech talk session where we,
uh,
you know,
watch youtube videos about technical things are non technical things,
uh,
as a group and discuss them and come here instead.
And I think that's a great,
a great way to improve gender diversity.
And,
and,
uh,
get us talking about it more.
Admittedly,
we've been talking about it a lot in the last week,
but,
um,
this is a,
you know,
it's a great way for a manager to have an impact on their team and,
and spread that knowledge.
Thank you.
Nice job.
So first of all,
thanks for coming today in presenting this to us.
The research and metric driven approach really hits it home for me.
Um,
I love data and this really is,
it really calls it out very clearly.
Um,
focusing on that data but also tying in people's perceptions.
question for you.
You mentioned out bias when you see it,
it only takes one voice.
So I've had experiences where someone will say something and it takes me like a
few seconds to like process what they've actually said and then I'm like,
wait,
what?
And then I'm like,
should I say something now?
Like five seconds of already gotten,
now it's 10 seconds.
And it's like,
so I'm,
I'm wondering if you have any like tips for calling that out because it
sometimes does take a little bit of time for me to process and then I'm like 20
seconds has gone by.
What do I do?
Kind of a thing.
Or if anyone else has any tips as well,
I'd,
I'd love to hear them.
So I,
I'm happy to answer that.
I feel like it's never too late.
Yeah,
just say it.
You could say,
hey,
you know,
it took me a minute because I was,
I felt like that was really inappropriate what you said and I just want you to
know and you could also go at it with the intent.
I mean I think another thing is always about intent.
So always assume positive intent from the other person and then you can have a
much greater impact in the,
in the,
in the feedback that you're giving.
So,
Hey,
I know you,
you might not have meant it to come across it this way,
but let me tell you how it made me feel and hey,
maybe you might want to consider not doing that next time.
Awesome.
Thank you.
So I'm a father,
I have four kids and I'm,
one of them is a girl and she runs the runs the house.
But um,
I feel like a lot of the,
or I believe that a lot of these things are a lot deeper than the workplace.
They're foundational in the way that we raise our kids and their promote values
and unintentionally by pink things for my daughter and blues things for my son's
and like what things can we do as parents and as you know,
in a,
in a sort of a grass roots since and as communities as we're raising our kids,
you know,
to help with this.
I mean,
that I don't even get me started with,
um,
I think there's a tremendous amount we can do as we're raising our kids.
I mean,
I can tell you just personally what I do.
Um,
so I have a daughter and a son.
And as much as I,
I mean I try to congratulate them for the same types of things.
So a lot of times parents will tell the girl they're really pretty and they
don't even mean it.
Or other people in the,
in,
you know,
in their environment will tell the girl they're really pretty.
And the guy,
he did really well on that problem.
Right?
And so I try to congratulate my daughter for problem solving and tell my son he
looks really cute,
but no,
no,
seriously.
And,
and,
and just really thinking about the language that you're using because that's
where it's,
that is where it starts.
Like when you get,
what,
what are you getting praised for?
How are people demonstrating love?
Are you,
you know,
telling your daughter that she's being too bossy?
Like too early on?
Um,
if there's an,
if you see two children playing,
because even if no matter what you do in your household,
you're not gonna be able to change what's happening in other people's
households.
But talking about it,
right?
And even in recognizing like,
hey,
so and so said this,
but in our family,
this is what we believe and this is how,
how,
how we conduct ourselves.
So I don't know,
you probably all have lots of ideas as well.
If anyone else wants to share
the question was given we know that lots of executive,
um,
promotions or higher co actually come x or external hires versus just internal
promotions,
how do executive search firms and other players that might be helping find the
slate of candidates for senior positions contribute to or detract from the goal
at hand,
which is to increase the number of women in these senior executive positions?
I'll tell you,
so we haven't specifically looked at biases for example,
in executive recruiting practices.
What,
um,
and,
and actually I think in general,
most people when they're talking to executive recruiters are pretty specific.
Say they want to see women candidates.
It's actually because it's a priority for a lot of senior leaders.
Um,
I,
I will say though,
in the end what it does happen is that more men are hired in,
at,
um,
at senior levels and laterally than women.
So in addition to different promotion,
um,
women getting promoted less frequently,
men are coming,
more men are coming in at more senior levels.
Um,
and so for that,
um,
you know,
we have an action it so I can,
I can hypothesize,
um,
I don't want to speak for the data cause I don't know,
we don't actually have the data underlying that,
but my sense is that is driven in large part by a lot of the same biases that
might take place in the recruiting and selection process,
uh,
for any role.
Right.
That um,
you know,
the way in which the rest of the way in which the a job Spec is written is often
much more tailored to a man and a man's background.
Often in the selection process,
there's a bias towards men.
People tend to look at men and see you.
Pr,
as I mentioned before,
see a potential.
Whereas women,
they look for performance and so the bar tends to be higher for women.
There's a lot of biases that take place in,
in that process.
And I think that's,
that,
that that's probably where it's coming from.
I'm not sure.
It's purely,
you know,
based on what's happening at the executive recruiting side of things.
Hey,
uh,
thanks for sharing all this with us.
It's a really just great to see like practical applications of things.
Um,
so I,
one thing to share that I feel like has been super personally helpful for me on
the changing your own language that uh,
things.
Um,
so a lot of us participate at time in both hiring,
so writing,
you know,
reviews are people who are coming in as candidates and also in the sort of
performance review process when you write peer reviews for all the people who
are going up for promotion or just generating feedback,
um,
and taking out gender pronouns entirely from feedback that you write,
I feel like has both a big impact on the way that I write.
But also for people who are going to just be reading feedback,
right?
This is going to committee,
it's going to hiring committee or performance review committee for promotions.
Um,
not having gender pronouns.
Like it does change the way that you have to write and the way that you use
adjectives.
And the way that people will interpret you're writing.
Um,
and it's made a big difference for me and just my personal like capabilities of
writing,
I think useful feedback about people.
So I would say for people who are doing that,
you know,
on their own or if you are working with other people,
even out of your emails when you're writing about what someone else had said or
recap from a meeting,
like trying not to rely on those actually pushes you a little bit further and
like giving useful descriptions of someone or their projects or what has
happened in a given scenario.
Um,
and it's like a really small change that you can make and that's very aligned to
a lot of the resume screen,
a blind resume screening tests that have been done where literally there have
been tests that have shown the minute that any understanding of what the gender
is of the applicant is taken away,
that all of a sudden the hiring becomes,
goes to parody.
It's amazing.
Right?
So exactly like the,
if you can take that away,
how much of a difference I can make.
So I'm a white Anglo Saxon,
Protestant male,
identify as straight a manager,
so on and so forth.
So like the Bingo of being part of the privileged class was to speak.
Um,
so I'm wondering from your research,
looking at many different companies,
like how do you go straight at that majority to affect change at scale?
How do you,
sorry,
what,
how do you,
how have you seen or how do you go at people like me at scale and organizations
to make them part of the change and not rely on the underrepresented groups to
stand up to make that change?
Well,
it's literally engaging you in part of the process,
right?
It's engaging you and being a champion of change in signing up to mentor,
sponsor a set of women and driving specific initiatives within the organization.
In fact,
it's really important and we've found that it's really important that men lead a
lot of these initiatives that is not all women led.
So I think the,
the real important thing is to get people like you to actually own and do and
lead some of this and sign up for this.
One of the things that I've done as a manager is if I see somebody doing things
that I know will be negative towards them.
So if they use language of,
I'm sorry or I,
that's the one that always gets me is the,
I'm sorry or I'm bothering you.
Or things like that to literally tell them,
don't say that.
Say it this way.
You know,
and this is why.
So call out those small things.
Cause I think sometimes when people hear the word mentorship they think,
oh,
I've got to take them to lunch and I've got to do this and I've got to do that.
It's,
it's the simple,
you're walking back from the meeting to your desk and say,
Hey,
I heard you say this and it,
you know,
negated what you were saying because of this reason.
Because it's grounding need to hear that like immediately and repeatedly.
And it took me a long time to learn those things.
Well yeah.
And that goes back to one of the real drivers,
which is getting developmental feedback and hard messages and people tend to not
do that for women.
And so telling the person,
don't go sit on the side the room,
sit at the table when you walk in,
take them the main seat at the table,
speak up in the meeting.
I want to hear your voice.
Don't use like,
and sorry and don't caveat what you're saying.
Be Assertive and forceful if if you need to and not meeting.
Like I think giving that coaching and that feedback is quite valuable.
Now of course not,
not,
not necessarily trying to um,
only promote one kind of leadership style,
right?
You also want to recognize different leadership styles and some people have more
assertive leadership styles and some people have more quiet leadership styles
and all that's fine.
But definitely giving feedback where people are taking away from their own
credibility or not stepping up and owning leadership opportunities the way they
can.
I think that's really,
really important.
Hi,
thank you for reinforcing much of what we tried to do here at Google with lots
of external data that's always necessary.
Um,
first I'd like to say that was Matt and he's actually one of my mentors.
So he's sort of practicing what he preaches already.
And I'm like the opposite of everything he just said.
So Kudos to him.
My question is,
do you have data around or a POV on,
um,
this idea that by focusing on women's empowerment,
gender parody,
elevating women in the workforce that that is discriminatory against men?
Um,
I don't think so.
Okay.
Um,
or that,
I mean,
so I mean,
we're so far from being discriminatory against men right now that I think it's
sort of,
you know,
it's,
it's cleaning up some of the issues rather than trying to put in place quotas or
you know,
things like that.
And so I think,
you know,
if anything is perceived as discriminatory against men or if there is something
like a quota that can be perceived in that way,
um,
that can be damaging to the whole cause.
Right.
Ah,
but so all of the things and the data that we've shown here has been about
things that are cleaning up.
The issue's not swinging the pendulum the other way around.
I would say.
I agree with you.
Just,
I'm always playing devil's advocate,
so thank you.
Thank you for that.
And I appreciate that.
Hi.
I have question in regards to both gender diversity but also age diversity.
So I was speaking with one of my Google mentors the other day.
We were talking about,
you know,
the job postings,
even on the Google side,
I don't know if you guys have seen,
but obviously it shows x amount of years of experience.
And he was saying,
do you read a study that even though,
so it says four years of experience required and some men they'll look at that
and they only have to not be like,
I'm going to go fry where girls are like I three but I'll hold back until I had
that forward before I can go for that position and so on.
I mean that's,
sometimes I have an urge and I'm like,
you know,
when I read the qualifications and like I could totally go for that.
But I see the level of experience I'm like obviously,
and being out of college and things like that,
you don't have that.
But in with technology nowadays,
it's,
those years of experience are really relevant to you know what's,
so I want him to get your opinion on those postings.
It's a really good point.
And there's two sides to that coin.
So one is the way in which the job posting is being written and should you write
it?
Well actually,
let me take a step back.
It is very much proven over and over that women tend to like to hold a higher
bar for themselves.
A man and a woman will go into the exact same review and the woman will come out
and say,
oh my God,
I did like,
here are the 700 things I did terribly in the mental that I rocked it.
Literally the same language.
Um,
and similarly,
exactly as you're saying,
men will be like,
ah,
four years experience.
I was in college for four years.
Um,
you know,
and a woman will be like,
oh no,
I,
well I had four,
I have six years of experience with four of the two of them weren't exactly
right.
And bubba like,
it is,
it is just human nature.
Um,
and a lot of studies have shown that.
So there's two things to do about that.
One is to educate women on,
um,
self advocacy and like,
how do I,
how do you start to think about yourself and actually reach for reach higher,
reach harder and be okay with taking more risks and things like that.
Um,
and I think that is actually an important part of it.
And we,
for example,
Mckinsey do a lot around that,
which is like how can you raise your hand and ask for more opportunities and be
more,
you know,
if,
if your male counterpart is going and asking all these other people for
promotions,
you sh,
you know,
you can do the same.
Um,
and then secondly,
I think there's also the part about the writing of the job posting.
So if we know that women read it that way,
maybe trying to shift the language a little bit so it doesn't say,
you know,
it,
it's,
it seems that the four years of experience is more of a nice to have.
Or you can write it in such a way that it does.
You're not playing to that,
that,
that bias.
I think it's a really good point.
One.
Okay.
Um,
you were talking a lot about,
thank you for being here.
Firstly.
So this study,
super interesting.
Uh,
you were talking a lot about self advocacy but early in the study we'd be hood
about how women want to get a lot for themselves.
I perceive to be aggressive or bossy.
How do you manage that,
those two perceptions?
So that's a really good question.
Um,
I think that it's about managing a way,
the bossy issue.
Like I,
I think the answer is not to let women not to tell women,
okay,
well then just operate within that bias and so we have to change the bias.
So you're right.
I mean I think there's,
when we get called it's a double edge sword,
right?
I mean it's sort of like the damned if you do damned if you don't wear,
where do we stand?
But I think you just,
I mean w self advocacy,
I think that the bar,
the,
the barrier between how women self advocate or the,
sorry the gap between how women self advocate versus men is,
is even bigger than the bear.
The gap between how women are perceived as bossy versus not.
So I would just sort of,
even though they are linked,
I would separate the two and address them each equally because I think they're
both very important and it's better to be called Bossy and still get the
promotion,
you know,
then to like not get it at all.
Thank you so much this awesome.
Uh,
and thanks to all of you.
It was really great Charlotte and you gave some fantastic advice.
The other thing that struck me as I was listening was just the awesome advice
that you gave each other.
And so I hope that each of you takes away at least one nugget from this
conversation,
whether from Charlotte and Mckinsey or from what some of your colleagues shared.
And I passionately believe the way we addressed this over time is really the
continuity of the conversation.
So many of the things that we talked about,
if we're able to sort of quickly and easily that back and forth what we heard,
what we saw,
what the impact was,
we will consistently get better.
So please keep the conversation going both in these settings,
but also in the hallways and continue to look to each other and,
and to all of us for tips to move this forward.
Thank you guys so much.
[inaudible].